this is a sizzling review fifty Shades
freed the whole review I'm gonna be like
this because this is probably how many
of you prefer to see this movie that
would be the best way to see the movie I
know I know what it's called Fifty
Shades freed no you didn't hear there's
like that book called grey written from
his point of view
hahaha they're gonna do oh my god are
you kidding we just we just got outside
from shoveling yeah I had to drive over
here so I had to make sure he could get
in cuz like we're in the middle of like
snow magna Rock yeah it's literally like
snowing right now there you go it's
still going
hopefully the exposure could sure that
but yeah pretty much and the first time
I came here up a little the first time I
came here I forgot the batteries either
drive in the snow again to come and put
it back fortunately he lives like five
minutes yeah but by the way we didn't
plan that that was a huge coincidence
what I moved but it's a totally worth it
for a movie I haven't seen that's right
we're doing the same shit we did last
time where he's gonna tell me what
happened in this film cuz people seem to
like that they seem to like watching my
react last time we left off I said my
wife is on our own for the third one
there was no way in hell that I would
see it again and then everybody online
told me you need to fucking see it again
and all I can say is you fucking people
well I'm so glad you love your fans more
than your wife this movie's almost a
marriage deal-breaker like to be here
I'll tell you what the marriage
deal-breaker would be if she
legitimately liked the movies she does
not what huh she kept going into it like
I did in the hopes that it would be like
the room like so we were what the first
one there just dolt they're stupid and
dull I can say now now that I've gone
through the whole trilogy the first one
was legitimately the best movie the
first the first one is the only thing
that resent
the real movie but it's not fun bad
right no it's not fun bad but when I
look back on the first one I was like I
mean that was the problem with the first
one they were taking trash and trying to
make it serious like no we gotta artsy
this up and you can't do that because
they want after them yeah they want to
correct it so plays like a demo reel the
cinematography in that movie is
legitimately good I'm putting on this
hat by the way because I have gotten
comments if people say you know you're
really bald and the lights like right
above I just like the way the exposure
is I'm like I'll look at my head I'm
like thanks shined is really bright I
just came in fast shuffle yeah that's
why I look like this that's why I wasn't
wearing my oh my it's gonna be too web I
don't care cuz he had that reflection so
yeah and then the second one I thought
well the offers involved so now we're
gonna get some real garbage real primo
garbage oh my gosh it and I'm so boring
as shit and now we're at the third one
and I mean that's the third film in the
series so we have to up the ante so you
want to take a guess some of the things
that are in this movie uh I hear
something about yogurt frozen yogurt
okay cream will get today okay that's
all I know
I know nothing oh and there's a baby cuz
following the Twilight bullshit there
has to be a baby just tell me this one
is an actual baby and not a CG
monstrosity uh uh uh you never seen the
baby all right
now flash forwards ahead like a couple
years to where it's like a two-year-old
but you never see the actual baby
there's no birth Oh
thankfully okay cuz that would been
hilarious because I imagine theory dude
what happened in the pleasure room she's
like strapped down like the baby goes
straight into like a sex swing like do
they instruct the child in the ways of
S&M I I don't know but but the fact that
she gets from explained to that kid how
they met this goddamn story if ever
there was a case for giving your kid up
for adoption this is it
and as nothing to do with the fact that
they're into BDSM I don't give a shit
about that it's the fact that there
- very fucked up broken emotionally
unstable people who should not be racing
but not a way like the Tennessee
Williams like well no no just you're
supposed to sympathize but you don't cuz
they're insane
no I mean his initial reaction was
you're pregnant
fuck you and he goes on gets drunk or
something so I'm just like yeah this is
gonna work out great um so yeah I'm just
like this this kids just gonna be
wrecked fucking wreck this is the first
one that's not over Valentine's Day
released aren't they usually Valentines
it's close enough
well that's bets because Black Panther
the much much better movie that has
black rubber and latex and things but ya
know so some of the things happen this
movie uh kidnappings Night Fights gun
shootouts car chases and it's all just a
big sex game no others like there's a
hacker court cases uh the surprise
pregnancy a near miscarriage and there's
a twist the twist is it's really fucking
boring in the last film didn't like
nothing happened that's what people were
saying when something happened nothing
happened and same thing here it's like
all of this shit happens and not once
did I believe a second of it or just I
just there was no suspense I'm like how
can you add this much craziness in one
movie I mean the final Twilight movie I
mean those were trashed - but bitch it
was hilarious
oh yeah like that was amazing that's
what I was hoping I hoping this is gonna
be like the last Twilight that's where I
might are the funniest that's what I'm
so it's it it is not that the film opens
up with the wedding of the century they
they get married like are they tying the
knot yeah all they're tying some knots
alright I'll guess they did they did
they use that any of the advertising
wouldn't have been just brilliant I'm
sure some idiots I feel like they must
uh that's way too good too
so and then they they go on their
honeymoon and it's like one of those
really awful Disney Channel movies where
all they do is just like vacation and
isn't being white and part of the 1% fun
like one of those montages where it's
like now we're in Venice and now we're
in now we're in France and now and oh
isn't it so magical that he's rich I was
gonna say there is I think you posted as
meme to this meme that says if 50 shades
if the guy from 50 shades wasn't rich he
lived in a trailer this would be the
scariest shit on the set of Criminal
Minds and that's what this turns into at
the end of the movie turns into a bad
episode of Criminal Minds but so yeah
you want the you want filmmaking fail
101 they break the first cardinal rule
of filmmaking there's like this scene on
the French Riviera and she's like trying
to go topless and Christian Grey's like
you can't do that the tabloids I get
don't show off your boobs don't you and
she's like what what's the big deal on
the French Riviera it's like a topless
beach look around Christian there are
boobs everywhere boobs boobs boobs boobs
who cares if you see my boobs and I'm
sitting here just going don't tell me
they want BPG 13 right it's really edgy
guy you know but it's a pg-13 this
there's there's enough money lying
around that there's no way but I'll tell
you this it is definitely our and not
like an MC you know they're so soft
and I forget them so quickly I just
assumed they're pg-13 but you're right
basically pornos with all of the graphic
porno bits removed yeah like so just it
makes the R rating but yeah in which
case why are you watching it yeah so but
yeah then there's no pornos I was like
the first thing I'm like don't tell me
about all the boobs you're seeing show
make it an interactive part of the
experience bring me into the move they
have to know so a lot of guys are
dragged to these movies so come on give
us love I was amazed well okay's so we
had bad weather last night the snowstorm
had started but I was still oh so there
was
less people there but for the 30 of us
that were in the cinema I was still
amazed that I counted like six guys that
was more than I thought it was gonna be
there cuz I thought at some point they
would have found a way up but now they
they were there and I was one of them
and I got sat next right next to some
like older lady who just was way too
into it and any time like Dakota Johnson
said something sassy she's like it was
actually kind of half-and-half it was
like half older people have surprisingly
young team I fit know my feet I thought
it was just middle-aged to elderly why
don't okay I don't get how this happened
cuz I did not see a single
african-american in that audience but I
swear I somehow heard cuz like from the
very back whenever like she would say
something or I have some witty comeback
I would just you're way in the back okay
look feed these 50 to 60 year old women
I mean this is the closest thing they
have to feeling edgy to feeling street
younger kids and I'm just like I saw no
black people in this audience I was like
did they were like they too were they
too scared to like they're just like I
can't be caught dead here we have to
speak in like did they like drop from
the rafters sneak in through Baghdad
like but and then my favorite is at the
end there's like some twist so like
early on there's this bad guy who's like
chasing them and it's like oh he went to
a foster home in Detroit and then
Christian Grey's like oh I went to a
foster home in Detroit and then at the
very end of the movie she's like showing
a picture it's like yeah this is the guy
that was chasing us and he says yes
spoiler alert like it matters by the way
and and he's just like yeah that's him
and that's me and she's like you were in
the same foster home and then like laid
the background edges here oh my god
watch so what they're brothers is in
there oh they just by I guess like nut
blood-related but they were in the same
foster home but like they were acting so
shocked there's this is like audible
gasp from the back of it they're just
person and this guy is doing all the
Shinda I mean women even pop into your
head maybe it's this guy
I just doesn't seem to hang out with
anyone else only you know I whatever her
name is cuz she's so amazing just like
advertised it like at that moment I'm
like oh they were in the same foster
like I'd be like forget all right there
I just remember when they did that I
just turned around like where are you
from but yeah so was the weirdest the
audience was like way too into it mm-hmm
like creepily so um and then at the very
end is like some stinger at the end and
Kristen gray says something I'm like I'm
just like I gotta get out of here and
like the old lady next to me goes excuse
me sir did you catch what Christian gray
said at the end there I'm like no and
geez guys how it sounded like it was
something important and I just sat there
and I'm like yeah no and I just turned
my wife I'm like they want to start
talking to us but the energy wedding to
this film
wedding of the century just like Oh
Charlie that's so fun being rich and I'm
just like that like it makes me laugh
cuz I feel like that's what's really
turning the way I'm like I'm like I feel
like that's where I'd be like woo
vaporous to buy you shit yeah so yeah
wedding of the century by you kinda well
done while they're on their honeymoon
somebody Brayton like is simple as this
guy like breaks in with a with a pass
card like visitor card or like breaks in
goes into like Kristen grazes his
corporate headquarters like
supercomputer room or whatever it's all
very bad fictiony yeah all very fanfics
you like the room where the computers
aren't things and then he did computer e
stuff and then set the computer
reminding that actual text from dark
fiery stuff and like his just got what
he does is he he basically shows up in
one outfit and basically he puts a hat
on and all of a sudden he's like
unrecognizable to everybody yeah it's
like I'm person now it's like I'm
maintenance now because I have a ball
cap and I'm like wow great security like
Christian Grey like this is like a Bill
Gates type like great security so like
Dakota Johnson meanwhile takes one look
at this guy so that's my former boss
that's asshole McGee or whatever like I
forget what his name even was cuz I
don't care but and like and she gets us
just by like it's just blurry picture I
was like wow I would have spotted that
just right but just like yeah that's him
he said he's after us why I think it's
after us I'm like well maybe because
like you frickin like took his job and
Christian gray and you I got him fired
and like it was like don't get me wrong
like in the context of the film I was
just like the fucker needed to go but
I'm just like why would he be mad at you
like to understand we're so normal so he
becomes the main bad guy the movie and
then there's just a lot of there's more
stuff in what you mean the main
characters weren't the bad guys I just
assumed they were evil bad people I just
I don't know how this marriage is
lasting I've basically just randomly
it's like you know what it is it's it's
got that like sad marriage feeling we're
like now they've just gotten to the
point once it's like let's go the
pleasure you know and it's like it's
just like just just like whipping her
needs to say you know this whole movie
feels like they're like they've settled
like they've settled marriage biddies
yes you know how I bear just start off
like you know just the normal thing
events like all things are king a little
standard you know and there was this
spice things up you know and then you go
into like all that stuff it's dense when
you start off there how do you spice it
up it's like it's like a bad porno
addiction it's like they're so used to
spicing it up and so like it
to it then now it's just lost any sense
of pleasure and nothing like a horse it
was like just once I would like them to
switch it up like once just once I would
like Christian Grey to be like let's go
to the playroom and then you just like
see him diving into a colorful ball pit
[Laughter]
like white plaster Gary bike ball gags
of it it's like all right it's bringing
a step up ooh
what are you gonna do it's bouncy castle
time and then and then like at the end
like security this movie oh yeah at the
end they're just like all right we're
taken to the next step we're doing it
like you know what's the safe word like
you know red or whether I remember that
just we're doing the slides and then
like slides but I'm not talking like any
slides I'm talking about the tallest
twisted ladder chutes and ladders I I
mean real hard core chuck-e-cheese shit
and then afterwards like you know
skee-ball and then pizza and coke and
then finally something to just switch it
up cuz I just like like the novelty's
worn up they just go through these
scenes and I'm like they're not into it
I'm not into it
and like the only people are into just
women who just don't know what a Google
search is because I'm like you can see
any of this shit you can see softcore
shit I like doesn't all have to be like
hardcore shit like you know I don't know
if they're scared or if they're just
like no the stories I feel like it's one
of those I mean like yeah I feel like
there's better things I could do it but
it's like one of those movies slash
books where it's like it's almost like
given permission to be a little naughty
that's why it's not super extreme it's
actually ridiculously light but it's
like oh well I can be a little naughty
here whoa
you're right just people that don't look
this up don't know anything about it but
what an excuse to you know indulge and
what they think is age my my favorite
scene is when my favorite scene is when
they're there on a plane and they're
like going on some vacation with her
friends because he keeps her behind
though I closed doors
shocker he's controlling and she's all
like pissed off about and I'm like wow
like even in this story it's the classic
I thought I could change so but but yeah
so Phi is like alright we'll do
something like I can be a benevolent
tyrant overlord BDSM creeper guy here
will go on a vacation like with our
friends and and we'll fly in a plane and
this events on the way back like they're
like getting like all into it just like
hey like hey I give me whatever looks at
this like some witty line cut to them
just like she's just like chained
against a wall and he's like yeah yeah
my wife and I'm just like they're still
on the plane she lost her shit at that
she's just like just burst out laughing
that was it the plane room the plane
room yeah it's just
Christian Grey hires these security
people and they're really bad at what
they do she shows up somehow this guy
broke in grabs her with a knife food is
like you come in with me Anna and like
drags around their jumps on you I love
this was like this seems like you're
into it I always say like you know like
that that's the problem though she
hadn't discussed what the safe word was
with this guy I always say like when 70
people in the war you should find his
may say this as possible because if you
get captured and they talk to you they
just be they bring it on I love but
she's so the security guys like I put
the knife down and then like the the
security woman who's got to be like
three foot five like literally like
points up like the gun at the guy said
it's like yeah drop it and like he tries
to turn her under something and she just
like freaking cold cots and gets his ass
on the ground I'm like first off as
security you guys are terrible because
somehow this guy got in in the first
place but like
they're off in the kitchen and like
she's wanting them like hey no is
anybody here it's like you think the
security guys would do like a sweep of
the room before security why does anyone
here why don't you just hey is anyone
here now they won't break you in today
why you asking the robber a second this
guy is the world's worst girl like first
off he brings a knife to like a gunfight
I was like why did you bring a butcher
knife this is America
you can literally we pass out gun he's
been coughing yeah it's like a PEZ
dispenser it's like hey you want some
semi automatics and he just brings a
butcher knife to this goes sound like an
idiot but of course like at the court
case they're just like well you seem not
gonna be a danger to society and you
totally attack this woman with a butcher
knife broke into this apartment and yeah
but you claimed that she had slept with
you first this a female judge by the way
this is like this is so inappropriate
like now that the hashtag me to movement
is happened I'm like ah but she said but
because you have no previous criminal
record even though wielding a knife and
you have two security guys testifying
that you held this girl with a butcher
knife um you get bail bang I know he
post post bail I know you killed this
five-year-old but seeing how he was the
first five bail bail so he gets out so
he's still running around and then while
they're on vacant lot on vacation to try
to put their like marriage back together
like he's like always like I'm worried
about you and she said I'll be fine it's
like but no I mean I'll be fine and then
there's legitimately somebody chasing
her and all of a sudden this is like
I'll be fine okay so they go and they go
to this place in the in the mountains in
the Cascades somewhere and like late at
night she's like eating Ben & Jerry's
unlike the kitchen table just like her
underwear and he like shows up and like
this stupid dialogue or it was like you
know like these some some stupid line
and then they like start
get at each other and I'm like okay well
you know put the Ben & Jerry's down and
go to town
like I guess it's with people here to
see nope they just decide that they're
gonna incorporate Ben & Jerry's now into
their sex life and I'll say this like
that was one way to switch it up I did
not see that one coming American dream
but she's like she like takes it it is
like she's slapping oh god she's
slapping a spoonful of cold as ice cream
on his chest and I'm just like that's go
let me take some he's like rubbing it on
her nipples and I'm like all I'm
thinking is cold
sugary sticky milky cream I'm like i
whatever your kink is that's fine but I
might I just got imagine it's
uncomfortable and then she uncomfortable
she takes the Ben & Jerry's of smooth
wood and like drips it down and it just
goes sliding down his happy trail like
an avalanche through the forest of pine
trees through the first like oh and then
she like she's like what they're like
lips and tongue like just goes down
they're like yeah that was like ice
cream and pubes no this is at least more
what I was expecting
that is easy oh this is the only time
where it's like it like sounds funny
ridiculous and I can even see some of
being like you know who you know like
it's so goofy but could be like I
favorite rhotic to an audience that
doesn't I think what terrified me is
just the audience had no reaction to
that I'm sitting here like truckin done
that I'm sitting here trying not to
simultaneously vomit and laugh my ass
pop my cherry Garcia oh no I'm telling
you this which I'm never gonna
look at chunky monkey the same way again
or or Dublin mudslide or chocolate fudge
super proudly yeah that I will still do
the cinnamon bun ice cream no cuz that
chestnuts but the rest of him ah not
anymore
every time I look I'm just gonna mention
there's pubes and so I would love if the
Stephen Colbert ice cream was the one
being you just so Stephen Colbert can be
watching and judging them the whole time
like while they're doing it's just
always in the background just colbert
going so yeah that happened then i mean
as far as lines go there was one funny
line it's not even a gray line but just
made me laugh so it's the security guy
follows anna into her workplace he
always seems to be everywhere except
when the bad guy attacks of course but
like Paul's in the security place and
like her her assistant she's all like
mmm and who is that you know it's like
oh it's a security guy like Angus you oh
ski uses like you know I can can you
find a place for him and she's like oh I
think I've got a place for him it's just
wow I'm talking about my snack talk
about my chunky monkey I just kind of
laugh cuz I'm like you know what you
went for broke in that one time I think
he got it yeah so from there the bad guy
keeps attacking and then basically oh
yeah she gets she finds out she's
pregnant
Christian Grey has a heart attack over
this is like literally like angry like
fuck this like comes bad drunk and like
his mom or something she just like puts
him to bed and it's like it's me okay
encasing her no no no no no but that's
what happens it's Anna that looks at his
phone and finds that like Kim Basinger
texts him it's like whenever you need to
talk again you know feel free and for
some reason that's it like all of a
sudden now she's just like I'm done I'm
a lock myself in the pleasure room like
and then he's just like looking for like
she's not here where could she be
nobody saw her leave it's like nobody
like puts it together that she went into
pleasure rumors I like it
so for some reason that's what sets our
off not the fact that he's controlling
that all the other things but the fact
that he went back to his crazy aunt mom
person whatever we got it's wrong
finding out that she's pregnant
yeah after getting drunk finding out
that she's pregnant that would go to
your mom and I think the other thing
that whatever the other thing that
shocked me what there's like this seat
like okay so she gets attacked by like
knifepoint like butcher knife and like
hair grab pulled knife to her throat
like shots nearly fired and everything
it's like it for what it is it's like
okay this is like this is like the kind
of legit scary scene you know nothing's
really gonna happen to her but I'm just
like wow like if that ever happened to
me like I'd be like holy shit like need
some time to recover from something like
that I'm hoping I'd be hoping a three
foot five cop would say it's literally
like a day later and she's back in the
pleasure room scarily like kidnapped or
murdered
yeah and now you've got me blindfolded
and are basically like halfway lay
basically like attacking me with them
yeah so then she's so then she's like
stop stop read read and like that's her
safe word I thought it'd be safer who'd
be fired by agent no read read it and
he's like okay I'm like oh okay I'm like
the movies gonna go there like it's just
too much like after everything that
happened no no you wanna know what it
was she was pissed off because he was
using it as revenge because she like
wouldn't listen to him so he said how do
you like him now how do you look at her
and she's like I don't like it that's
not love like that's revenge I'm like
that was the problem
look I just the weirdest things upset
these people I don't know like I'm not
into that scene but if anybody watching
this is if you're in the BDSM scene
would would you just be
let's day after you're like violently
assaulted just be like hi I'm right back
into the game like or would you just
feel like maybe need to take a break
because I kind my nerves are a little
jittery like yeah I get maybe it was
like no I like do this every night guy
holds a knife to my phone I don't know
shit I know the responses are gonna be
listen this doesn't represent anything
it and I get that that's a legitimate
point I'm just like wouldn't you good
so that happens and then finally then
there's a car chase in the middle of
this movie we're it's like we're being
followed
it's the bad guy like big shot and
they're on like the Alaskan viaduct and
like Seattle the the big double-decker
expressway that runs through Seattle and
they're like weaving in and out of
traffic that gets stuck back as a CO
that do this I'm like on that Highway
are you shitting me that highway never
moves I used to live in sin no way
during the day oh no they have one scene
where she like gets stuck behind like
this card she said come on buddy brew
like her that's the whole choice you are
lucky you are doing 65 on this road are
you shooting me now try doing that in
the 405 with a 5 up there like geez so
come for the yes curbs like that
so yeah there's like a car chase and
even that is just boring there's like a
scene where he's just like hey a bunch
of this giant like 12 million dollar
mansion that was my favorite like he's
like I bought a bunch of that so that so
that you can have a home and home first
off he's like well what do you think
aren't you gonna say something and I was
like the first thing I've ever said is
like you know you can discuss these
things with me like my wife and I
haven't agreed we love those Lexus
December to remember commercials and we
oh we have this mutual agreement a Lexus
December to remember if we buy something
major like a car the other one is
knowing that's not a surprise gift the
only thing you can give the other person
is the giant red bow what do I do with
the bow after that that's always my
biggest question sure okay I know
there's a lot of questions about the car
but would he do with that bow I just
like yeah he's just like budget swimming
though man to say well aren't you gonna
say anything
and she just goes like like it'll like
these purse little lip kiss like three
or four times
I love it III turned by sorry I turned
to my wife shoot that mansions cute I
love milk the door I turned to my wife
and I said if I ever buy you a twelve
million dollar house and all I get are
three little pecks on lips that ain't
happenin
that's fair it's not like you I was like
you'd better be frenching me Hawker this
is like Bruce Wayne layer of Croft
Scrooge McDuck money I mean this is like
ridiculous yeah I'm like twelve million
dollar house I had better get one long
French kisser that thing you'd better be
a record breaker no I expect like just
suddenly somehow the pleasure room just
comes outside and you just do it in for
everybody like you don't even wait just
somehow it's all right there it has a
pleasure I'm actually right here so tell
me how you think there's some side plot
about the the architect wants to redo
the house like not listening to and and
like totally hitting on Christian and
then Anna lays the smackdown I was one
of a few scenes that I kind of just
enjoyed just cuz she like they've got
the plans thrown out and already hates
the plans and this this chick is
obviously hitting on Christian like
hardcore and like just ignoring Anna and
it's just like well it's about what
Christian wants and I was like no it's
about what we want and so finally like
Christian leaves and she's like so like
what should we do should I just draw up
these plans or like Anna just sits her
ass right on the plans and she's like
listen
it basically says we're going to the
house the way I wanted and if you want
this job at all you're gonna stop going
by husband and then afterwards I just
one little loud audible
[Music]
and then a little I'd like to top it up
oh and you have to clean that up yeah
just like super chocolate fudge brownie
and cherry because I'm lactose
intolerant so that was like slightly
amusing but it's like but then they sent
out because she's like also I think the
architects like also hitting on her
friend's husband but then in the end you
find out that no they used to date and
it's so that the husband could like get
a wedding ring to propose to Anna's best
friend and I'm like twist like and then
boring spankings like that's what it
feels like it's like the most boring
plot without any suspect you're thanking
your baby okay she's just like here's
some tits yeah I just feel like this
movie would be more entertaining if like
Anna wasn't a real person it was like
just a sex doll and like the same
conversations the same everything
Christian great stir smoothly yeah he's
just paying someone to take in and the
car you know and like text back and
stuff like that it's all in his mind
like what a riveting movie this one's
you still want to know what's going on
his mind or and this one you clearly do
you know how this this movie ends sex
doll chunky monkey oh god I wish any
nose would have been better except
chunky monkey actually I don't like
bananas and I don't like ice cream with
bananas in I think this bananas so like
you can ruin chunky monkey for me that's
okay no okay so what is it Christian
Grey's sister gets abducted by the bad
guy the crazy boss from the second film
every time we've seen the sister was she
in the last one I think she was she's
been there I think from the beginning
alright she's like this she's like a
side character she's one of the
girlfriends and she said no it's you
she's like one of the
from Twilight who they're always just
kind of there but you don't really know
jack about them I really care so she's a
changed Christian so much he he cries
now and and he only does it while
masturbating not to step up or something
I don't know so she like she goes
missing and she'd get like Anna gets a
call just like missing something like I
have like your like Christian Grey's
sister and she's all like tied up as a
he's like here's what I need I want you
to get me five million dollars and I
need it like in 10 minutes or something
and like you're gonna do this or else
she dies and don't tell the cops or
anything and don't tell Christian or
anything I've got people everywhere I
know what I'm doing there'll be a pickup
parallel just do and she's like like
it's like you'll you'll figure it out
just like you figured out how to get my
job it's what a kind of weird person to
kidnap - does she have no other like
when it makes sense for like doesn't she
have like a friend or like the secretary
whenever assistant you wait for it wait
a second it's like okay it's like if I
thought that makes what you're always
gonna I'd be like well that's awful but
I mean like that I got other people
let's see more you have to that's one of
the big quiz is that the secretary at
her workplace at the publisher is in on
this kidnapping yeah
like when she gets into the pickup card
the Secretary's there and she's like why
are you doing this like shut up
just give me from like and but the thing
is if you were watching the movie from
the beginning from the get-go she's like
oh so now you marry the Christian greats
like how can you cha it's really great
it's like well best of luck to you
like wanders off of like that sexy walk
that says I'm like so pissed off right
now like an angry why doesn't contact
Christian Grey I don't get this lot oh I
don't okay or will this all
quote-unquote make sense oh no it's not
gonna make any sense it's only gonna get
worse okay so okay so she's like okay
okay I gotta do this I gotta do this so
is it first okay
let me let me make one thing perfectly
clear this is the lamest bad guy ever he
like just looks constantly like he's
just got like just kind of like crazy
eyes and he's unkept and he just he
doesn't he I don't believe this guy
could kidnap a dead fish I don't think
this guy could kidnap Princess Peach if
she was like bound gagged thrown in a
sack and had a sign on her that said
free up yeah mailed to him FedEx he
couldn't kidnap her and like this guy is
like such an idiot he went down in the
office brought a butcher knife to this
and I'm like I'm supposed to believe
that somehow he's a super hacker
arsonist genius master kidnapper who was
like rigged this whole thing and come up
with this whole scheme and he's a master
blackmailer tell us this he would be
doing other things he wouldn't be
focusing on her of his kidnap they're
literally trying to tell me that this
guy is like some super genius that
belongs on silence and lambs or criminal
minds or something but he looks like
that drunken guy who get like that
drunken wee he looks like that drunken
redneck who gets arrested on cops for
doing donuts in the bowling alley
parking lot they pull him over as like
that's what he reminds me of and I'm
like this guy like really this guy
accomplished all this all right whatever
so he's in some warehouse somewhere in
the greater Seattle area she she goes to
the bank and what is only the worst bank
manager I've ever seen it's like Oh five
million dollars okay cool um well here
you'll need to write yourself a check
and you know um all right can I see some
ID like oh all right and and I'm just
sitting here and I'm like wow well I
guess you be great million dollars get
you three pecks on the cheek is the bank
manager though I'm like we've just away
we're alerts oh yeah I'm just like to be
rich in white like all I I was like man
it's like how do you just walk out with
fight and she's like yes and I'm gonna
need it um in a bag with a big wallet
inside on it practically like that would
have just been the ultimate just like a
Scrooge McDuck money sign on it they
literally give it to her in a big
lebowski style drop-off duffel bag and
he's like well do you want somebody to
help you carry it because it's gonna be
very heavy it's five million dollars in
like under and finally he's just like
your husband wants to talk to you she's
like Christian I hey what's going on
like you're at the bank like there's new
like withdrawing like money like are you
leaving me said yeah and he's just like
okay uh you know what just whatever you
need to do like here get handover back
to the bank manager and she's like hey
he wants to talk to you in the bank man
she said hello
free money giveaway and he's just like
whatever she wants just do it that's all
yeah that's I said he's like okay what
[Applause]
like as a bank manager I'm like this is
the most suspicious like this is the
most suspicious shit I would have like
so many red flags would go up I
literally would be like you know what
I'd like to call the FBI in on this
before we uh but now he's just like okay
well we just won't walk out meanwhile
Christian gray world's greatest
detectives are gonna suck huh
something's going on I need to get to
the bank right away and it's in trouble
and then the security guards like oh by
the way your sisters missing the guy
literally delivers it like that like by
the way your sister's missing like it's
seriously delivered pretty much like
that and he's like okay uh uh-oh gotta
be related like no shit Sherlock
so she goes outside with five million
dollars in a duffel bag just walks out
the bank and the bank man's like have
fun like don't don't get
any trouble now define Italian like I
would have assumed she was heading to
Colombia that this is a drug thing but
uh or she was involved in a Ponzi scheme
and she's skipping towns like good at
least get you a few briefcase I mean the
duffel bag is so cliched she gets in the
car there's the secretary and she's a
given phone like gives it foam like
throws the phone at the winds ik what
shut up just shut up
yeah like drives away in a blue Durango
it's like can you not find a more
obvious guy like yeah I know this is a
very bright blood blue colored blue
Durango I'm like how about something
just black or gray or nondescript like
the security guy like walks up like
behind the car can't be more than 12
feet away not even more than that it
speeds up
with cell phone and and he's like
watching it speed away down the alley
with cell phone an and he goes the
getting away in a blue Durango I want
you to remember this number ap one maybe
was an eye for 207 maybe it was for 807
get about four license plate combos out
of that ap one for two yeah that was the
license plate combination that I can
still remember the next day because it
was just right there and I'm like why
didn't he tell why they pass on the
license plate number particularly
because like I swear to God in Rhode
Island when we were at the con there the
cops like shot the wrong person or
something because they were looking for
a pickup truck and it was the wrong
license plate number like something
there happened like that last November
and I'm like this is important
information like you could track this
computer and go with a license plate
closely matching these sets of numbers
somewhere in there
let me guess there's an old Durango
somewhere no no no they take it all the
way to the warehouse but on the way it's
just like oh my god
like Ana kept your phone in the duffel
bag and like switch phones so they
follow her using the tracker on the
phone so they're like 10 minutes behind
Ana's shows up
so it gets so whiny in the last half cuz
he's like you know shows up basically
he's like you know handover the money
and then she pull he starts beating her
and then she's pregnant so he's like
kicking her in the like stomach or
whatever nice you know yeah happy
Valentine's Day
bruised uterus look happy miscarriage
look just because she's into it doesn't
mean the fetus is into it okay that's
just not fair so yeah and then the the
Secretary's ago shut up I say a lot of
things look he's just so just completely
he is so unbalanced and so bad no you do
know there's no way I'm just like I
really as I said this guy could not
kidnap a dead fish you know I don't
believe he could do any of this the best
he could do is get drunk and get rested
you get arrested for drunk and
disorderly like that's all I see him
doing but it may be getting some sort of
drunken fist fight at a bar but yeah so
she gets knocked on the ground and then
like he turns around to say something
and she pulls out a gun that she stole
from Christian Grey stole from his desk
he has a gun in his desk and then fires
hits him in the fucking kneecap so he
goes down he's still very much alive and
then Christian shows up and it's just
like oh my god are you alright it's okay
I bought both these people Oh curses now
as I told my wife after the movie ended
I was just like she's got sisters that
was like you know honey in the event
that any of your sisters are kidnapped
and the ransom call goes to me I'm going
to make sure not to tell you not to call
the cops not to call anybody withdraw
like five million dollars then withdraw
all our life savings ourselves be the
hero steel yeah everything wrong deal my
brother-in-law is gone and then tried to
do all this myself and you know I mean I
know it's your sisters by blood relation
and not mine I mean we're all extended
family but you know I would do this
without you know
any of this I just that's the life
lesson I took away from this movie and
she just like doing this that's fair I
mean it makes you feel any better I
would leave Doug to rot
yeah but yeah we had a good laugh over
there I was like she literally did every
wrong thing I'm you see I was like okay
if you want to discuss with Christiane
not calling the epithets but it's like
you don't even - it's his sister
not yours you dumb broad such a weird I
know like why that person she has no
other friends how would it make more
sense to kidnap gray to kidnap him I
mean like none of this makes any sense
you could try to abduct him you could
have she's got her best friend that
worked there the one who said oh I can
find the secretary is the one that's in
on it right yeah why doesn't she just
pretend to be kidnapped like oh no like
that would have made it so much more
sleazy had somebody like Edith well it
turns out at the end it's like oh she
wasn't totally evil he had slept with
her and then blackmail they would like
the pictures or something and I'm like
well then Jennifer could have done that
plot like you could have just said
you're gonna pretend to be kidnapped or
else you're gonna it's a minimal amount
of work for you and I don't blackmail
you and we get money and we're good or I
could take this up a thousand notches
and abduct assists like it I mean she
was stupid enough to do all this for you
know his sister she like it seems to me
she would be stupid enough to do it for
anybody
I'll say this for like and make all the
wrong decisions like wanting to save
somebody's at the prom but in like
making all the wrong decisions and going
along with it I'll say it's for two
movies where very little happens it is
fine assembly they just throw all this
shit out of nowhere all of it doesn't
match any of the younger and Santa and a
morir miscarriage cuz at the end they
like like try to like trick you and make
you think like oh my gosh the baby like
and now the baby comes out fine and then
the final shot is there at there the 12
million dollar house
with their kid wandering around and like
TV we're happy playing in the backyard
and I'm just like isn't that what it's
all about being really really rich
[Laughter]
yes Geico endo maybe when you're older
yeah that was it and for a movie where
all of that shit happens I swear I kept
looking at my watch and I was just like
time has stopped it's like I swear to
God I could play it was like we saw the
movie at 7:00 and I swear I kept seeing
8 o'clock again and again and again like
I'm leery I'm like I'm in a time warp
I'm I'm in stasis
time is standing still for this movie
it's like the watch is broken
something's wrong get me out of here
I literally had a moment in the middle
of the movie where like this we were in
the middle of the raging snowstorm and
I'm like if I just walk outside into the
snow and never return would I prefer
that to sitting through the rest of
movie and I thought long and hard about
I was like cut to you from the end of
the shining June yeah Rosa body I you
know when I hit the restroom I just I
stared in the mirror for a while just
like what are you doing what he was
meanwhile the makers of this movie I was
like that's what we wanted you to do you
did you watch I I had like an
existential crisis like a but I just was
staring at myself just like it's so bad
so bad I and you know I don't feel don't
cry for me because there are no more
tears to shed I don't feel bad for
myself I did this to myself for you
a-holes and it's and I don't I don't
feel I don't feel bad for anybody who
showed up to see the movie cuz by now
you know you know what you're gonna get
and I held out no real hope I thought
maybe it would be like the final
Twilight movie because they're all just
not so bad it's funny until that last
one but I didn't think it was gonna
happen um the only people I do feel
sorry for it
those who are into safe consensual BDSM
tab that out there is this kind of a
representation of life I feel I might
you have my condolences and I might just
no I think most people don't think that
represents anything and the the sort of
people that do just god help them no no
I feel like the people that do you think
like yeah this is kind of what it is and
everything like they're never gonna
fully really do it they'll be like oh
use a shoelace or something cool now I'm
fifty Shades do you know like they're
never really gonna do anything anyway
and they're never gonna like probably
talk to anyone they really know is this
stuff I don't very people I kind of feel
sorry I don't think it's worth getting
that worked up over just cuz I don't
think it's gonna have the impact we're
already on the third movie and did you
know that said just felt like this just
came in one to nobody gave a shit yeah I
feel so I feel like if you're in that
community you have my condolences but I
think this is gonna blow over in a
couple years people are gonna remember
this it all the other people I feel a
little sorry for I mean I'll be very
happy Pulu V's uh I don't think any of
them really want to do it they do it
because they'll get their name out there
you'll get recognition it'll you know
and again I mean after watching the
first film I mean it's one of those
things where it's like I'd hire some of
those people for other films I mean you
know it's a terrible movie but it's like
I can tell that it is trying to be
stylized it's actually trying to do
something whatever I wouldn't be like oh
never never use those people it's like
no I could see putting them in something
else you know I'll tell you oh that's
one last thing
I wish I came here my name is Ruby well
first off Mamma Mia - trailer right
before fifty shades of gray I literally
sat there members like this is hell I
have arrived fine but I am in hell where
did this happen I kept going through my
life I was like at what point did I die
somewhere this happened like I'm in hell
but the second thing was there was some
sort of old lady I can only describe as
like you know those old guy comedies
were it's like Clint Eastwood Dyer
Butler again Freeman and a bunch of
other old actors like Zoomers doing shit
in Vegas like or bucket list or like
whether like those
he kind of like first lives it but it
was just like a book club maybe that's
what was called book club I'm sitting
through this trailer it's like all of
these older female actresses and I I got
no problem with them it's just like but
as far as I could tell all the actresses
like it was a decent lineup but all of
the comedy written for him just terrible
but it was all based around reading
Fifty Shades of Grey and I'm just like
am I being that is the movie am I being
attacked like did the fourth wall break
I'm not watching a movie about I'm
watching a trailer for a movie about
reading Fifty Shades of Grey before
actually watching Fifty Shades of Grey
that's kind of like what like I'm like I
really am in some sort of weird Twilight
Zone wait I forgot I think when we went
to see Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
mind while the trailers are playing I'm
like well I'm really excited to see this
Charlie Kaufman movie at the time you're
like you know what's Charlie you know
Charlie coughing wait direct I said well
no he's a writer and then the trailer
for confessions of a dangerous mind came
on it I said written by Charlie Kaufman
okay oh that's a writer it's like yeah
it's like well what else do you write
and all of a sudden the trailer for
annotation came on is this Charlie
Kaufman has written Being John Malkovich
and I'm like it was no it was like that
and it just I like went for my wife's
knee and like gripped it because like
literally like all the worst like jokes
you could think of are in this and then
like haha Fifty Shades of Grey
like some secretary or like the old
ladies are just I like losing their shit
and I'm like gripping my wife's knee and
like squeezing it like clinging like a
hawk to its prey and she's just like
honey you're hurting me there's some
god-awful Melissa McCarthy yeah it was a
melissa mccarthy trailer nexor it's all
like I'm an older mom going back to
college and I'm just like I saw daughter
I'm like I saw back to school in 80s
we're doing this shit again and it's
just like haha it's cuz I'm old and fat
and uh I'm just saying I had a lot of
sex with his younger something something
my talking vagina not like that was a
joke and I'm just like I can't be at
that point I was like I can't take it
and of course everybody around Zach and
the guys are all on their phones I feel
like this is an audience of Windows from
Bob's Burgers oh my god I love Linda
from Bob's Burgers oh my favorite I
don't want to do that to lit I like
Linda from Bob's Burgers I don't you
know I mean like it's what this thing is
like oh I'm good I'm good I like to be a
little edgy just have a little fun but
but not too much they were a bit like to
vet Amer's like favorite it's a lot and
like you know oh it's adorable and a
little naughty a little risque you know
like I feel like it's a lot of it was so
weird because it was all soccer moms old
ladies and then like the random like
early twenty something year old girl
like is so it was like a combination of
bingo night a PTA meeting and then just
somebody showed up to the rise just the
weirdest group of people and the one
african-american group in the back that
snuck in because I never stopped but
yeah and then and then five guys who
just we all looked at each other like we
were like no we were like war survivors
this is like I've seen shit he's like I
said shit just the righteous nod of like
we've been there Semper Fi
oh god it's like let's watch this is us
it's like no I gave you 50 shades free
we're not watching this is us for like a
month okay I was overall I look out cuz
my wife generally has a really good
taste and she doesn't like these movies
is us is not we went but it's clearly we
we went we went into this like just for
shits and giggles and like we were
hoping for something better and that's
the thing the biggest mistake the movie
made is it got rid of the inner
monologue I realized once you take the
inner monologue out the
is just nothing to this story like it
really is dumb but if yammering dumb
it's it's got nothing to it so they
remove the inner monologue so there's
nothing left to the story and the
because I say it's like take out the
talking from the room it's like well
yeah that'd still be stupid and weird
but wouldn't be fun half of it is the
talking and what they're saying and how
they're saying yeah but yeah I can't
complain like for the most part our
tastes really well then we'd both hated
this movie so yeah I'd say the only last
thing is uh there is a scene I should
you not in the middle of this movie
where she's looking for books to publish
he's like that's it this is the one I'm
gonna publish isn't published this book
is plastered everywhere in the movie
it's like this is gonna be a purgatory
and I'm just like you are actively
mocking me movie aren't you you are
actively making fun of me you're sick
movie you're sick yes just like here
here is this a purgatory men purgatory
man I really it felt like that scene in
top secret where they're just like well
well when you put it like that Muslims
like a really bad movie they both look
to the camera yeah it just it felt like
it felt like that it's is like this is
purgatory this is like wow like was that
on purpose like I robbed you gotta
choose one is it purgatory or is it hell
cuz you said he'll earlier and they're
supposed to be different
I'll go with purgatory because he'll was
being in the Mamma Mia trailer knowing I
still had two hours of Fifty Shades
freed left purgatory is just being stuck
in Fifty Shades freezes or wearing off
swearing off Ben and Jerry's for the
rest of my life well that all sounds
awful that's barren is that sounds
terrible I'm so glad I didn't see there
was a snowstorm and my wife has no
interest in seeing this nor did I I'm
gonna make it my life's goal to do an
NCN this developed oh no I'm gonna
pester you
to watch them again you're gonna suffer
I mean you up for it is it all watching
together just so and you have to watch
it again is it really worth it yeah I'm
just telling you now it's material like
we I'm gonna I'm gonna be that I'm gonna
be like that kid from better off dead
$2.00 every other day
50 shades until you do it I don't
whether oh come on it'll be great I mean
we can't do the sex scenes we do we'll
do sock puppet theater and then when
they get in a cup so you can have your
content was not across off you still
have this idea to do these soccer mom
don't you want to see mm-hmm
correct it'd be more entertaining the
builds I'm sure but grab a paddle one of
those fans that like goes around oh yeah
like that's the bondage bar she's like
looking at a Christian and they like I
swear to god they do the recap montage
of like remember all those times I so
stupid Twilight movies yeah yeah they do
this like montage of like all the times
and she's like walking in at that
wedding in the costume and there's like
singing mmm yeah when you had cold metal
balls shoved up your snatch that's some
I wonder and it shows like the sister
lobby kidnapped it stuff like good times
good night or throat good times when he
shows up when it shows her is wrong when
she's like I'm pregnant these days joy
like together sometimes says something
should do an edit of that like when this
film comes out just like yeah just like
yeah it shows some of the early like you
know good moments and it just shows all
the terrible insane stuff that shouldn't
be in that montage on a trapeze
really I don't get it he's such a dick
it gets just obsessed it's just a but
she's she's insane and she's batshit and
he's an abusive dick and I just match
made in heaven so how they have to form
a family
that's the way they all became the bound
up punch punch bondage punch
that's a baby game the bondage runs and
Alice is still in the military before we
love Alice she's like in skin tight
latex little oh my god yeah now we have
our spin-offs now we have a way for
these movies to continue and it's all
told from her point of view oh my god
I would love just like her inner
monologue just describing what's going
on like Alice the may just constantly
describing all the crazy shit that's
going on just her like well that's
strange and she always sounds like a one
line their Hawaiian vacation where they
fall under a tiki curse
statue curse or whatever yeah maybe I'll
review of these movies if I can work it
many talents from the Brady Bunch
I got nothing anymore I'm I've been
shoveling all day and I'm spent and
right biggest show of her yeah this is
sucked the energy out of me will go from
enemy shoveling bullshit to shoveling
snow but there it is
Fifty Shades I hope never to hear any
more about any of this again what you
going to do well in terms of views but I
just
there's no nostalgic connector like I'd
have to wait like 10 years or something
like I try to have some nostalgic who's
the lion I change my focus big to be a
person but I always like that lion like
needs to lie in history's unmarked grave
of forgotten lie well somebody wrote it
for him speech no it's a speech after
9/11 I figured was stated heroism was
some speech to join citizen steel I
think I well it was that an axis of evil
something-something axis of evil but ya
know I always liked that
like that's totally where this building
belongs so there it is you're free go go
do something else anything for watching
these movies just um yeah I think at the
bondage bar and I really did feel like a
prisoner well that's okay this is the
one thing I'll say before I leave cuz I
love this joke is that they said you
know that after Fifty Shades was
released at the sale of rope and
hardware stores you know went through
the roof and I commented by saying is a
lot to reading Fifty Shades of Grey I'd
want to hang myself too and that's still
I think the joke I'll go out on so there
you go first joke ever made about fifty
Shades of Grey
hopefully it'll also be the last so it's
gonna be okay oh this is the movie it's
gonna be okay
you